welcome to this video playing Kelly on
Carlo de Moura from Italy very frequent
opponent and not one of my favorite ones
I have a score of 3 out of 14 this is
really disastrous don't really know why
why is it so bad okay let's see we get
them get a Slav here with queen bee
three variation that I'm quite quite
like actually for white okay he's going
for quickly be 5v5 it before ok I can go
to d3 that sets my IDM down I don't want
to fall too far behind on the clock user
quick player yeah ok still AM
need to cover if I am ok so is opening
opening up here directly
okay if I take and then go back here
you're trading is not not really great
maybe maybe just here and Tom asked the
Queen wed assume is going
maybe Quincy seven or something okay I
go age three here you probably will play
Bishop here anyway to age five but at
least I've gained him gain the tempo him
all right yeah he's still threatening to
take on your form hmm
yeah I don't like it so much this is not
the position I like really before
yeah maybe play it like that I can go to
g6 instead of exchanging I forgot about
that that's really a bit that's not very
nice it should be six okay maybe we'll
see one is still ok ok this is not not
so terrifying yeah queen bee 70 probably
need some reliable protection for the
palm
yeah this is the kind of sentence after
which the opponent just takes upon when
you think okay now I discover them you
cannot take it and then hit then exactly
then you blunder it ok Jim then be three
night I can go nite b3m not be too I
mean hmm well this might be a bit I can
play looks you I cannot believe it Roxy
one should be should be totally ok for
me ok are here must take loops have
whoopsie one a proxy one ready yeah yeah
i also have to show p.m.
hmm let's do Holly solid really
I'm not enthusiastic about others but it
should be it should be M tough to break
down maybe I can play I can take it and
play rugby son okay this he prevented
maybe he's he's intending to play f6 and
eff yeah this I need to prevent
hmm
yeah well night you find it's not really
helping him much
I want to want to be relatively quick
not get into huge time pressure
yeah I have 25 covered I don't really
think I have any problem here I can give
the check now even check okay Bishop e7
isn't okay i can go here attending
Bishop to b6 maybe hmm maybe I can no no
I have okay me to go here and maybe
night night 24 would be very nice okay
prevented it okay but I'm still very
active here with my king especially
want to take here I don't be five so
that so that I can check the pawn Knight
a 30 90 form time warning
I forgot that wanted to play g4 first
and forgot that he can take on reform
yeah that's a nice endgame no really
nice black resigns yeah plus the time
but it's a window of course ah very very
important win 90 to win against this guy
once in a while and I was under pressure
again I didn't really like the opening
outcome don't don't know somewhere this
is a total totally normal line yeah II
six this is not not especially active
for him but he managed to get in the
activity yeah I cannot I cannot take
probably Queen be a drug see am NOT not
a good idea and so I went back and I got
into trouble maybe I should really take
on the aid this wasn't all this wasn't
wasn't really nice maybe I need to do
something else the computer wants to
play if I am I didn't like it because of
this but maybe I'm I'm maybe i discarded
this too quickly now that that's
actually quite nice young what I didn't
see at all is that after something like
that I hear this even before us very
strong this kind of stuff winning I can
play the cymbals this is very strong
with 23 possibly coming which instantly
coordinates my pieces that's that's very
nice yeah t I'm just I'm just somewhat
worse and always struggling I don't know
about 94 I was more afraid that he would
meet the Queen and
ask my queen where are you going I
probably have to go to be one due to the
the discovered at acxiom and this is not
really comfortable yeah after that i'm
not sure i think i should i should be
okay ready i have a decent centralized
position check again yeah I'm not not
sure here I mean this is this is
somewhat more comfortable for wide I
probably shouldn't do win but yeah here
here there was a problem I wanted to
play em here I wanted to play g4
immediately him after which she can take
her and dent and draw so went back he
can play G for himself but he didn't do
that and here I'm probably winning the
soap configuration is is is okay and it
keeps yeah i just said as a unit in
itself it just keeps the kingside
totally totally blocked and i can he
enter here and wind up in the pond or
win the porno differently like and like
I didn't then in the game so nice nice
win select problems out of the opening
but managed to to fight back into the
game thanks for watching